- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is continue our journey
trying to understand
what the expected value
and what the variance
of a binomial variable is going to be
or what the expected value or the variance
of a binominal distribution is going to be
which is just the distribution
of a binomial variable.
And so, like in the last video
I have this binomial variable X
that's defined in a very general sense.
It's the number of
successes from N trials,
so it's a finite number of trials
where the probability of
success is equal to P,
so the probability is
constant across the trials
for each of these independent trials,
so the probability of success in one trial
is not dependent on what
happened in the other rials.
And we also talked in that previous video
where we talked about the expected value
of this binomial variable
we said hey, it could be viewed
that this binomial variable
can be viewed as the sum
of N of what you could really consider
to be a Bernoulli variable here.
So, this variable, this random variable Y,
the probability that's equal to one,
you could do that as a
success is equal to P.
The probability that it's a failure
that Y is equal to zero is one minus P,
so you could view Y, the outcome of Y
or whether Y is one or zero
is really whether we had a success or not
in each of these trials,
so if you add up N Ys,
then you are going to get X
and we use that information to figure out
what the expected value
of X is going to be
because the expected value of Y
is pretty straightforward
to directly compute.
Expected value of Y
is just the probability weighted outcomes.
So, it's P times one
plus one minus P,
one minus P, times zero, times zero.
This whole term's gonna be zero
and so, the expected value
of Y is really just P
and so, if you said the
expected value of X,
well, that's just going to be,
let me just write it over here,
this is all review,
we could say that the expected value of X
is just going to be equal to,
we know from our expected value properties
that it's going to be equal to the sum
of the expected values of these N Ys,
or you could say it is N
times the expected value,
times the expected value of Y,
the expected value of Y is P,
so this is going to be equal to N times P.
Now, we're gonna do the same idea
to figure out what the variance of X
is going to be equal to
because we could see, we know
from our variance properties,
you can't do this with standard deviation
but you could do it with variance
and then once you figure out the variance,
you just take the square root
for the standard deviation,
the variance of X is similarly
going to be the sum of the
variances of these N Ys.
So, it's gonna be similarly N
times the variance, N
times the variance of Y.
So, this all boils down to
what is the variance of Y
going to be equal be?
So, let me scroll over a little bit,
get a little bit of more real estate
and I will figure that
out right over here.
Alright, so we wanna figure
out the variance of Y,
so variance of Y
is going to be equal to what?
Well, here it's going
to be the probability
squared distances from the expected value.
So, we have a probability of P
where what is going to
be our squared distance
from the expected value?
Well, we're going to get a
one with a probability of P,
so in that case our distance from the mean
or from the expected value, we're at one,
the expected value we already know
is equal to P,
so that's that for that possible outcome,
the squared distance times
its probability weight
and then we have,
actually let me scroll over,
well, I'll just do it right over here,
plus we have a probability of one minus P,
one minus P for the
other possible outcome,
so in that outcome
we are at zero
and the difference between
zero and our expected value?
Well, that's just going to be zero minus P
and once again we are going
to square that quantity
and so, this is the expression
for the variance of Y
and we can simplify it a little bit.
So, this is all going to be equal to,
so, P times one minus P squared
and then is just going to be P squared
times one minus P
plus P squared times one minus P
and let's see, we can factor
out a P times one minus P,
so what is that going to be left with?
So, if we factor out a P
times one minus P here,
we're just going to be
left with a one minus P
and if we factor out a P
times one minus P here,
we're just going to have a plus P.
These two cancel out.
This is just this whole
thing is just a one.
So, you're left with P times one minus P
which is indeed the variance
for a binomial variable.
We actually proved that in other videos.
I guess it doesn't hurt to see it again
but there you have.
We know what the variance of Y is.
It is P times one minus P
and the variance of X is just
N times the variance of Y,
so there we go, we deserve
a little bit of a drum roll,
the variance of X is equal to N
times P times one minus P.
So, if we were to take
the concrete example
of the last video
where if I were to take 10 free throws,
so each trial is a shot, is a free throw,
so if I were to take 10 free throws
and my probability of success is 0.3,
I have a 30% free throw percentage,
the variance that I would expect to see,
so in that case the variance
if X is the number of free throws
I make after these 10 shots,
my variance will be 10
times 0.3,
0.3 times one minus 0.3,
so 0.7 and so,
that would be what?
This right over, so this
would be equal to 10
times .3 times .7 times 0.21,
so my variance in this situation
is going to be equal to 2.1.
Is equal to 2.1
and if I wanted to figure
out the standard deviation
of this right over here,
I would just take the square root of this,
so if we want the standard deviation,
just take the square root
of this expression right over here.